[Music]
pepsi's number fever campaign
in the philippines has probably gone
down in history as one of the biggest
marketing disasters in history mainly
because
of a human error that led pepsi to print
more winning caps than they planned
the resulting chaos caused riots
civil unrest and even deaths
reporting this story took over a year
and it resulted in me flying to manila
in the philippines
to meet unlucky winners and to find out
exactly what happened
back then in the 1990s
[Music]
my name is jeff mesh i'm a journalist
based in los angeles
i wrote the story for bloomberg
businessweek about pepsi's number fever
campaign
the philippines is a really interesting
country it's made up of thousands of
islands
and it's also a country that's very
heavily influenced by america
american culture is everywhere you look
in the philippines they're obsessed with
frank sinatra music
for example they love all things america
and that extends to their their love for
soft drinks
pepsi cola coca-cola in the 1990s
it was everywhere
pepsi and coca-cola were embroiled
in what is now known as the cola wars it
was a fierce
battle for market dominance
number fever was already a really
popular promotion
it had been rolled out in america to
great success
and so pepsi decided to roll it out
internationally
particularly in asia they thought it was
the answer to their problems
they thought it could finally help them
beat their biggest competitors
look for the winning number and sorry
sorry source every day off on tv radiant
newspapers
you could be a millionaire a million
pesos
or 68 000 doesn't sound like a lot now
but in 1992 that was a phenomenal amount
of money
you've got to remember that in the
philippines at the time the average
monthly income was about 100 so
a million pesos was wealth beyond
anyone's wildest imaginations
number fever caught fire in the
philippines
kids were saving up their pocket money
to buy a bottle of pepsi
parents were squirreling away all of the
bottle caps in bags
you would walk down the street and
people were going through trash
trying to find discarded bottle caps it
was a national phenomenon
pepsi boasted that half the population
of the philippines was playing it
number fever boosted pepsi sales every
month from 10 million dollars
to 14 million it had a huge impact
on pepsi's bottom line
number fever quickly became number
hysteria
maids were being jailed for stealing
their employers winning
bottle caps there was even some murders
over over winning bottle caps people
were fighting in the streets
over these caps there were signs
that there were going to be problems
with number fever
very early pepsi had rolled out the
competition
in chile and a garbled fax had caused
some kind of problem with the winning
number
they'd announced the wrong one in chile
causing riots
there were signs that there could be big
problems ahead
if they didn't keep their eye on the
ball so in 1992
pepsi decided to extend the campaign in
the philippines
and they announced that the competition
would go on for a few more weeks
one night on the television news they
announced
the latest winning number three four
nine the problem was three four nine
had already been allocated as a
non-winning number
in earlier campaigns so there were
literally hundreds of thousands
of bottle caps with three four nine just
floating around
the philippines hundreds of thousands of
people
all across the philippines thousands of
islands were finding winning bottle caps
three four nine three four nine some
people had ten
lucky three four nine bottle caps people
were dancing in the street
celebrating they thought their problems
were over they were millionaires
it's still not certain exactly how many
winners there were
of lucky 349 bottle caps but we know
that pepsi printed over 600
000 of them pepsi realized
very early that there was a problem
hundreds of people started arriving at
their bottling plants with their lucky
bottle caps
they realized something was seriously
wrong pepsi tried to solve the problem
by offering a small token donation to
anyone that brought a lucky bottle cap
to their bottling plant but it wasn't
enough
people didn't want just a handful of
pesos people wanted their million peso
prize
within a year violent protests and riots
outside pepsi factories
would leave dozens injured and five
people dead at one
pepsi factory in the philippines a
grenade was thrown
through the window it killed three pepsi
employees
anacita rosario was a school teacher
living near manila in the philippines
she was one of the tragic victims of
this whole thing
she was walking to a nearby store to buy
some rice one day
when a molotov cocktail was thrown at a
pepsi truck
in a violent protest it bounced under
the truck and exploded
it killed her and an innocent bystander
who was just a child
and injured many others when i was in
the philippines
i'd tracked down anacita's daughter
cindy and her husband raul
it was clear to me that they were still
very upset by the whole thing
you know a family had been ripped apart
by this competition and raul
told me that he'd never remarried he'd
uh
told me that he'd gone to meet pepsi
executives
after his wife was killed and he was
angry he
he said to them you know this wouldn't
have happened if it wasn't for you
if it wasn't for number fever
the biggest revelation from my reporting
was rumors that pepsi was somehow
involved
in bombing their own trucks i found a
newspaper report with a headline that
said
pepsi goons bomb their own trucks
and when i visited the mbi the police
department in the philippines they
presented me with documents
and interviews with people who claimed
that pepsi
had paid them to cause riots and to
cause trouble
outside their plants in order to
destabilize
the situation and to frame the
owners of the coalitions that were that
were fighting them
to try and curry favor i just thought
that was
that was so shocking and of course pepsi
denied it but
how bizarre that a company would be
accused of bombing their own trucks
the contest had sparked so much anger in
the philippines
because it landed at just this really
weird time
in the philippines history it was during
a crazy election that was
wracked with allegations of fraud the
philippines was in a kind of love-hate
relationship with america
they loved obviously the american aid
and finances that was pouring into the
country
but at the same time they yearned for
independence they wanted to be their own
country
vicente del fierro was a local preacher
living in manila and he hated the number
fever
campaign del fierro thought
pepsi's number fever campaign was just
one of the many ways that america was
asserting its dominance over a third
world country
he hated seeing his fellow countrymen
get ripped off in his eyes
by this huge multinational american
company
he wanted justice del fierro rounded up
over 800 winners
of 349 bottle caps and he got them all
together to sue pepsi
for over 400 million dollars to be
divided
between those holders of lucky bottle
caps
[Music]
del fierro took money from
some of the people who could afford it
they paid him 500 pesos to
help with legal fees but for people who
couldn't afford
the money he would just represent them
pro bono
the alliance right there is to build up
pressure
on that team and so you see people
marching
[Music]
he flew to america and he hired two
consumer lawyers here in america to take
on pepsi
he had a meeting at pepsi's headquarters
to try and resolve the problem
but he said he wanted to take it all the
way to the highest courts in america
when those cases were heard in america
those courts decided that this was a
problem
that should be heard in the philippines
not in america
back in the philippines del fierro
continued his case
in the filipino courts at one stage
there were arrest warrants handed out
for nine
pepsi cola executives which he saw as a
big victory
we don't know if those arrest warrants
were ever upheld
but it made newspaper headlines across
the country
pepsi did not take kindly to del
fierro's campaign
they tried everything to shut him down
they sued him for libel my father had to
attend three times
a month for a branch 145 and another
heating for the brunch 113a
also three times a month also um there
was a time
my father's was hospital to do heart
failure
still he had to attend the two branch
hearing
otherwise for not attending the judge
will issue one atom customer pattern
my father passed away january 13 2010
after staying for almost
one year in the hospital he died a
complication due to heart failure
after the death of my father i was
inspired to do the website
pepsico will be remembered for what they
did to the consumer in the philippines
and to my father
when i reached out to pepsi for comment
for this story
they claimed that they didn't have
access to anyone
who was working at pepsi that was around
in those days
they also said that during covid19 they
didn't have access to their their
documents about this but
you know they were very they were very
careful to say that they were sorry for
everything that happened
and we do know that pepsi did try
everything to try and make this right
the pepsi number fever disaster
cost the company millions we know that
they paid
up to 10 million in those goodwill
payments
but the financial effect could be much
greater
after the disaster we know that pepsi
sales dipped
they were overtaken by coca-cola again
pepsi's number fever disaster changed
the legacy
of that soft drink in the philippines
forever
some people of a certain age won't touch
it for many people
pepsi is a taboo word a lot of the
people that i spoke to were still quite
traumatized
by their experience by that experience
of
winning a million pesos losing it
and then returning to their normal life
in poverty
in manila
you